Film Courage: How would you handle if you
were working on a project with great people
(magical, great chemistry) but they're a little
bit behind on paying you?
How would you approach that?
Brad Rushing, Cinematographer: What do you
mean by a little bit behind?
Film Courage: A couple months?
Brad: That would probably be a long project.
I'd hand it off to my agent.
I'd tell my agent to deal with it and they
have a legal team and I would keep doing I
mean I certainly wouldn't confront any of
my creative partners or probably even tell
them about it.
I mean I might if I felt they would have influence
with the production company but I wouldn't
threaten them.
I wouldn't be one of those guys like I'm going
to walk off again.
I'm committed to the work first and even if
even if those good-for-nothings never paid
me I'd finish the job and never work with
them again but to me somebody else's bad behavior
is not a license for me to also have bad behavior.
Again if somebody's being unsafe if somebody's
being jeopardized or harassed or harmed that
would be different I would certainly become
defensive and confrontational in that responsibility
as to whatever degree was necessary in the
moment but by and large I believe in diplomacy
and professionalism and if it's just that
my pay is late I certainly wouldn't be happy
about it but I'm not going to harm the work
and I'm not going to harm my relationship
with the parties who are not directly involved
in that predicament.
Film Courage: How about earlier in your career
when you did not have an agent?
Brad: Well it would still be a similar strategy
but I would not jeopardize my position on
the project I would I would not go into defcon
mode until after the project wrapped and even
then I wouldn't be impolitic about it I would
I would be professional I would I would give
them notice and then I would either get a
lawyer or I would file a complaint with the
labor board I would do the right things if
I was in the union I would or I mean I am
in the union now but if I was at the time
I would report it to the union and that's
the other thing too is if I was on that job
in addition to seeking my agent on them I
would stick the union on them but if I was
all on my own I would like I said I would
just wait until I would not be happy but I
would put up with it until we were done and
then I would go through the the legal avenues
available to me and if I ended up getting
boned in the end and even if I didn't even
if they ended up paying if I had a bad experience
and felt they were being predatory I would
just never work with them again to answer
that it's like look in in withholding my pay
they're already harming me right but if I
relieve in my own well then that's adding
harm if I provoke them in such a way that
they spread bad stories about me even if they're
in the wrong I don't know who they know if
the producer or the director or my the actors
if I create a situation where they think I
have some bad behavior that's gonna harm me
I don't there's no value in that to me that's
just that's just adding adding my own harm
to it and I just don't think it's gonna improve
it and that's that's just based on my value
because again I'm their first and foremost
for the work and the relationships how much
time do you spend each day improving your
craft as a cinematographer well see that's
one of those formula questions there's there's
just no formulas there is no bullet point
on my calendar every day
I nebulously engage I read the news I read
IMDB PRO news I engage on social media I belong
to networking groups I belong to groups specifically
about film lenses I belong to cinematographer
groups I belong to professional groups like
the Canadian society cinematographers the
visual effects society and I what are people
talking about what are the articles they're
posting I might come across an article and
post it so it's really I mean I do my due
diligence and I do my check-ins but if it's
a day where there's really nothing on those
boards or on the news then then I probably
don't do too much if it's a day that there's
significant amounts of stuff if I have the
time then then I'll be watching some videos
and reading some articles maybe bookmarking
if I don't have the time I do I do I'll do
webinars and workshops and in in a normal
area era where we're not in a in a pandemic
I'll go to trade shows and product demos which
in as much as they're important to learning
about your craft and the new technologies
they're also networking opportunities and
it's fun to me it's not it's not it's not
work I mean again these are these are toys
it's like what's the new toy what's the cool
thing it's instead of a 4k camera you have
an 8k camera and why should I care and now
you've got these affordable anamorphic lenses
where did those come from and how are they
different from the tens of thousands of dollars
lenses and now you've got these rgb leds that
could do any color under the sun and they
can do a cop light and they can do a strobe
and they can do fire flicker and I just I
love that because cool that's a new toy and
I either rent it or go out and buy it so again
there's no I can't tell you how many hours
a day but it's certainly one of my focuses
it's one of the things that just like when
somebody reads the news they check the the
the national section and the international
section and the the comics and the one ads
for instance it's like that's one of those
things that every day I'm like okay what's
what do I need to check with how much time
do you spend trying to book your next job
i could say 24 7 considering I have a website
I have I have posts and and social media identities
on linkedin and to me that's like little fish
poles with bait that are stuck out into the
into the water 24 7.
I network I plant those seeds I have people
out there that I hope are recommending me
and saying good things maybe you would call
that passive but to me that's all sometimes
those would get me more work than me picking
up a phone or or asking or going to lunch
it's those it's those those ripples you put
out into the world just like you obviously
did your research on my website I didn't have
anything to do with that I mean I created
it but I you and I didn't talk about it in
terms of in terms of me personally it really
depends on the days when when when California
Christmas was blowing up I was looking at
IMDB films in pre-production and just reaching
out to people because I thought now's the
moment I can reach out and say hey I've got
a number one film but you have to balance
that with life and I could easily be a workaholic
as I've already kind of let that I would work
through meals and through the night and I
network and hustle far more than I shoot there's
this great quote by Orson Welles and it's
something to the effect that he he he probably
made a mistake becoming a filmmaker because
it's two percent making movies and 98 begging
for the money to make them I'm paraphrasing
but that's the essence of part of that quote
and it really is I mean so much of our work
is getting work what I like to tell people
that I am professionally unemployed because
what most people do only a few times in their
life in between jobs I do constantly even
when I'm on a job I'm looking for work so
so really if you looked at how I spend the
hours in in my day I'm professionally unemployed
when you first started out was it the same
percentage of time that you were looking for
work absolutely not and that's naivete I really
felt build it and they will come I really
felt that I mean I had never been a freelancer
before I didn't understand the dynamic of
working as a freelancer I didn't understand
the importance of networking I had only ever
worked for a company where they meet you once
and they hire you and then you just keep showing
up and doing the time card until you quit
or get fired so it really was a huge learning
curve for me and there were a lot of illusions
just like when I moved to Los Angeles I thought
oh it's a huge city somebody's going to hire
me somebody's going to give me a job and I
was so full of malarkey and I guess mercifully
so because because if I really realized how
hard it was going to be would I have done
it probably but it I wouldn't have been as
hopeful and optimistic it would have been
more oppressive to live with the reality of
what lay ahead of me instead of being blissfully
ignorant.
Film Courage: Do you think working at these
temp jobs prepared you because it's the same
thing like when you would work at these temp
jobs and one of these things would end and
okay accounting doesn't need you anymore I
don't know what you were doing but and then
you had to go and let the temp company know
I'm available this week?
Brad: Yeah I mean in little ways I think because
because like you could wait for them to call
you if they had a job for you but you could
also wake up at 6 00 a.m and call and say
I'm available and you were more likely to
get something so there was that incentive
be proactive and I'm not a morning person
I mean left to my own devices I wake up at
10 so for me to wake up at 6 00 a.m that was
a super human feat it's not so hard if it's
a call time and I'm getting paid but just
to call wake up and make a call because maybe
I'll get paid to go to a job that I really
don't want to do oh my goodness yes well we
also don't want to go to the clinic and get
shots but we have to so it's just I'm at that
age now you have to get a colonoscopy every
five years it's I'd rather go to Disneyland
but there are things in life you have to do
and when I was out here calling the temp agency
at 6am was one of them and it was again it
was a good habit it was discipline it's like
do that thing you don't want to do because
you have to no your boss isn't telling you
to and your mom and dad and girlfriend aren't
telling you to and if you don't nobody's going
to be mad at you you just aren't going to
work.
Question For The Viewers: What is your favorite
part of this video?